yeah I uh I see what went wrong the last
time and I'm not going to let you down
please don't okay costumes are the cost
of Humes that's not it that's not it
that's not it take it these are the
nominees for achievement and costume
design
okay the Oscar goes to Colleen Atwood
Fantastic Beasts and Where to Find Them
thank you um truly Flor stink told me I
was going to win tonight I didn't
believe him at all I was like what um
obviously I didn't prepare anything
thank you to Warner Brothers for their
tremendous really support supportive um
Team Steve capian my amazing director um
lovely David Yates it's just like a
special treat to work with him and my
amazing team and the rest of the people
who I've forgotten about tonight thank
you all very much my kids who are here
with me thanks so
much